so you got to play a fun new mode that
they have which is arkon mode which
allows you and a friend to play together
in a 1v1 setting so it's not as daunting
as it was before you know you could be
building units I could be micromanaging
the actual units or vice versa um tell
me more about you know your experience
with dark on mode it really is basically
one on one except it's two-on-two you're
basically playing competitively in a
cooperative way so it's two people on a
team but it's only 11 group of unit so
you can split up the activities the way
you want like one person can do face
building one person can take care of the
battles and lead around the units and
stuff like that or you can just do
whatever you need to do to survive which
is sort of how it came down in the match
that I got to play so sadly we didn't
get to play as any of the new Protoss
units that are coming up than me and the
new expansion instead it was it was
terran vs terran it started with my my
teammate doing the the base building
thing while I I went out to scowl I did
the usual thing that you would expect to
do during an RTS match um but it was
really interesting actually to did he
stuff up like that because I could
really focus on uncovering parts of the
map I could focus on how I want to get
the units spread out across the map to
to see what was going on we actually got
a tet that our base got attacked fairly
early on but because I'd been scouting
pretty well we were able to squash that
like almost instantly and then we were
able to sort of expand really quickly
because he could focus only on the base
building and on the build order and
things like that so so is it was
actually a lot of fun to do that and I
think it's a good introductory way of
learning starcraft 2 especially if
you've been sort of intimidated before
or you don't play RTS is a lot and
you've heard a lot about like how
cutthroat star trek to can get online we
also didn't get to see certain things
but we did get to hear about certain
things that are coming in like
the avoid specifically new Protoss units
the the big one being the adept and the
Adept allows you to essentially make a
ghost of the unit that you can
individually control elsewhere it can't
be attacked it can't attack others it's
going to just be there and after a
period of time you can take the Adept
that created the ghost and just teleport
it right there but I didn't get a chance
to play it I have no idea exactly how
it's going to affect gameplay one thing
I forgot to mention and I should mention
about starcraft 2 the legacy of the void
closed beta those invites are going to
start going out on March 31st of course
that's the day the invites start going
out so that doesn't mean if you've
signed up you're going to get a chance
to play that particular day but we do
know that it's going to start happening
then on March 31st so something to look
forward to and hopefully I'll be one of
those people and I can get in and start
playing some Archon mode may be with you
hopefully you can get me into I mean
there's gonna be a bunch of new units
will have to see which ones last because
in the last heart of the swarm there
were some new units and they're like oh
that's really cool and then they kind of
canned it before release but you know
the lurkers back all that stuff so we'll
get to play it hopefully on the
thirty-first yeah looking forward to it
you
you